over a year for you you can give me two
minutes at that point in my career I
didn't really fully understand the value
of being in a franchise I was just like
how many times can I play this character
and and now I realize that you can play
that character as many times as they
want you to
[Music]
Ray Donovan you got a job for me tell me
what it is
not
thanks for the pen you got a nice house
no wait Mr Donovan
exactly what do you do
I knew what a fixer was I mean they've
been around
forever and in the old days when in the
studio system you know when actors were
under contract in various Studios there
were these guys who were
contracted to protect them and to keep
them out of trouble In Harm's Way which
with some of these actors was fairly
difficult so that was the first
incarnation of fixtures that I knew
about and then of course as we moved
into the age of litigation they became
some of these insane lawyers who go
above and beyond the boundaries of what
their practice allows them to do to
protect their clients and to go after
people after doing it for seven years it
was a dual-edged sword I was relieved to
be done but I was also disappointed that
we didn't have a chance to finish
the ark The Narrative it felt early it
felt like we hadn't done that we hadn't
achieved that yet with where we stopped
and then the next thing was just how you
know you shoot these things and you do
this work
kind of in a bubble like in the theater
you you know you have an audience and
you you can feel them reacting and
but sometimes with these TV shows you
don't know you don't know what's out
there and you don't realize
the extent of the support you have and
it was I was really really moved
by how upset the fans were that we got
canceled and and how they rallied to get
us to finish our story and that was that
was a great feeling
tell me I'm crazy
maybe I know
good hope we did our best with the time
we had and the shot we had but you know
Ray could have gone a lot further I
don't know
if anybody's really interested in you
know Ray with a colostomy bag but I was
really really grateful that
um people stayed with us so long and
that people cared about us enough to
actually write to the network and
petition to have us complete our
narrative and as far as I was concerned
the movie was for the fans
what was actually an episode from a
previous season that I'd already started
to work on with David that that we ended
up expanding into what became the movie
so we'd already started that work and it
was me really loving the actors who
played young Rey and young Mickey and
wanting to fill in some of those blanks
the sort of you know do the origin story
a little bit and and pursue that it was
an extraordinary cast I was like that
was probably the hardest part of leaving
that show is that that becomes your
family and John will always be like a
brother to me and and Eddie and and dash
and Paula uh Pooch it's hard to describe
that feeling of how close you get when
you work together that much over that
longer period of time and then to not
see each other it was a really hard
period of adjustment for me
Scream one through three
I thought it was super cool I mean I'd
never worked in the movie business
really and suddenly here I was at this
thing that was like
really a hot ticket yeah the decoy
scripts and signing ndas I don't I
didn't think I would ever have to do
something like that but yeah
I was very excited all I knew about the
first scream was I hadn't really done
much at that point I just gotten out of
school and I was like this is the most
anyone is ever going to pay me to walk
up some stairs because that was really
all I had to do in the first scream and
then the film just took off on the backs
of all these other actors and Kevin and
and Wes it was a phenomenon I had lucked
myself into a job because it was ongoing
and then we did Scream 2 and and
ultimately screamed three Kevin really
was the genius behind the script and he
was open to collaboration and all I
remember was thinking you know this
guy's kind of a ham cotton like he likes
attention I think that was the piece
that Kevin was interested in that he
sort of ran with I I think I suggested
something like everybody gets their 15
minutes cotton wants an hour well I
don't know I don't know Sydney I don't
know uh maybe because I deserve
a little exposure
I mean come on come on so write my name
through the mud everybody thinks I'm
some kind of Psycho Killer and all I'm
asking for is my little Diane
Sawyer interview to maybe get my side at
that point in my career I didn't really
fully understand the value of being in a
franchise to be frank I was like let me
get out of this while I can you know get
out of get out while you know while
things are going well and I just thought
it would be fun to be one of the iconic
kills from the top I was working and
doing a lot of stuff a lot of other
stuff in New York and theater and I was
just like how many times can I play this
character and and now I realize that you
can play that character as many times as
they want you to I kind of suggested
that they they knocked me off part of
the device of the the movies was that
you know somebody in the first five
minutes gets killed and we really don't
expect them to get killed which now I'm
kind of kicking myself because I would
have liked to be in
screen
it's five six I can't remember what
number what number it is
X-Men Origins Wolverine
your little mind games don't work on me
I was really just following the script
that I was given and and the script that
I was given outlined these brothers who
were kind of two sides of a coin one
that
who was able to control his rage better
than the other and that the problem with
both of them was that they had this rage
in them that
which was part of their superpower but
also part of
part of the trouble initially I was so
excited when when Hugh came to me and
then I realized
oh this is a this is a superhero thing I
went to Hugh and I said there's a suit
right he's like what do you mean he's I
was like because because you know the
muscles and everything that's
that's not real is it he's like
oh mate you gotta you gotta work out
that was the beginning of my tutelage
Hue teaching me how to train there was
this part of my toolkit as an actor that
I wasn't taking advantage of that I that
I always thought your body is your body
and that
you know changing it
was not
part of it for me uh and and Hugh taught
me how to do that I was having a time of
my life you know I had I'd done a bunch
of stunts and fight choreography was
something I always loved and this was
just two months of like I was in heaven
I was having so much fun and
building the character with Hugh I was
working with somebody that I just I
really enjoyed working with um Lynn is
somebody I'd worked with before we've
done Hamlet together and it was just a
great trip we were in New Zealand we
were in Australia it was um
I look back on that time very fond
memories
they didn't ask me
no I mean I don't think it was I don't
think he was part of that story I didn't
you know he wasn't part of that story I
would I would have loved to bring Victor
back anytime anywhere
but um it wasn't part of that narrative
I'm wondering if I'm getting a little
long in the tooth so to speak but
probably not for sabertooth
[Music]
and trying to understand why Sabretooth
is always coming after Wolverine it's
like why why is he always coming at him
and I and for me it made sense when
these guys were pitching to me that they
were related that they were two sides of
the same coin and um you know I always
loved that that narrative art from the
comics that
Sabretooth just shows up on his birthday
every year to whoop his ass I just
thought you put that anywhere I mean
Ryan did such a great job with that
transition because I felt like it was in
many ways so antithetical to who that
character was in Origins but I'm glad
that Ryan was able to correct that
mistake
I love dogs
I've always been a huge fan of Wes so
when he finally asked me to do something
and he asked me to play a dog which is
something that I actually excel at in my
own home I'm sort of known for my dog
voices I was really excited because I
was like not only am I going to get to
work with Wes but I'm going to be right
in my sweet spot which is dog voices and
of course I get to my first session with
Wes and I and I'm doing all my silly dog
voices and he's just like yeah no I
really I really sort of just wanted your
voice
and I was like oh that's I finally
get to do my dog voices and he really he
just wanted my voice you're my new
master my name is Spots I'm at your
service I'll be protecting your welfare
and safety on an ongoing basis part of
what's so great about Wes's characters
especially the animated ones they're so
human that he just wants those sort of
naturalistic traits on on the animals
but it was um
it was a really really thrilling
experience for me I think Wes is on a
very very particular cinematic Journey
because I've done another film with him
a couple more we just finished asteroid
city which is coming out soon you'd have
to ask West this but for me I see the
progression of the films and I think
that asteroid city is a natural
progression of the rest of his films
it's actually a film within a film and
in terms of the acting on it I was
really intrigued by how specific he was
about the acting style because I think
the progression in his film from bottle
rocket to asteroid city is really
compelling to me how he uses actors and
and and and even this stop-motion
animation part I think it's all part of
that that there is I think almost a
world in which he wants to merge
those two forms and in Asteroid City and
I I think he does it he does a pretty
great job of it how Wes uses actors is
is uh is integral to films you know
they're part of his whole thing and not
everybody can pull that off you know but
when you have someone whose vision is so
specific and clear it's really
satisfying to let go of certain elements
of control knowing that
you're going to go somewhere interesting
you're gonna you're gonna be led
somewhere that's going to be
um compelling
spotlight
whether Mr Garrett feeding is a crank or
not he says he has documents that prove
the Cardinal new as I understand that
those documents are under seal okay but
the fact remains a Boston priest abused
80 kids we have a lawyer who says he can
prove law knew about it and we've
written all of uh two stories in the
last six months had been a huge fan
Marty Baron as an editor and as a
journalist in general and I was
extremely nervous going to Washington to
meet him I just I couldn't imagine what
he was thinking that who's this guy from
this Ray Donovan show who's coming to
play me to my surprise
it seemed like he was just as nervous
and so that was a really sort of
interesting meeting but watching him
work and knowing
how principled he is and how important
it is
for him to hold
powerful people accountable and to speak
truth to speak specifically to speak
truth to power and how well he's done
that and how what a kind of gift he's
been to the communities that he's worked
within and how often he was not from
those communities was a really
interesting story and I thought that Tom
and Josh did such a great job showing
the isolation that he felt
uh there or or that they suspected he
felt for instance in Boston there was
something about his shyness and his
quiet power that I just thought was
interesting and I thought worked well
with that theme of isolation that that
Tom and and Josh had fleshed out in the
script that is one of the proudest
moments in my life is to have
made Marty Baron happy because I was
terrified I mean whenever you're playing
characters who exist or are alive it's
even worse it's a lot of responsibility
particularly when they're people like
Marty Baron but you just have to kind of
trust that you're not responsible to
them you're responsible to the to the
narrative that you've been given the
script and and your character is really
just playing a role in something that
expresses an idea and a theme in a
particular way so if you if you stick to
that more often than not
um it's the best way to go that's the
fun of acting that's the fun of making
films is you you get your hand at a
script you read that script and you try
to as an actor I think it's our job or
at least this is what one of my teachers
Lloyd Richards used to say that that
that an actor is an instrument of the
playwright you read the script and you
try to figure out what that playwright
is trying to express or in the case of a
film what that screenwriter is trying to
express and how your role accomplishes
that what you need to contribute to the
film to accomplish that and part of what
I love about the work that Tom and Josh
do as filmmakers is that it's a lot of
little pieces that are assembled
together to express something and
Marty's was a little piece but it was a
really really important piece and for me
it was it was about those people who
have the courage to hold powerful
entities organizations accountable I
really feel like Marty uh as an editor
spoke to a Time
when journalists were very very reliable
small life
and once we're up and running we'll need
more people so why don't you come back
in a few months
my parents gonna make me marry my
brother if I don't get a job but it's
not as bad as it sounds I'm adopted but
still would you want to marry your
brother most people know the story of
Anne Frank it's kind of been an American
curriculum for a while hopefully it
stays there people are challenging that
now but not everybody knows meet peace
who is the woman who actually hid the
Frank Family for almost two years and
fed them and kept them alive until they
were found I think seeing that story
from A New Perspective is part of what
keeps it fresh I think the other thing
that keeps it fresh is Belle's
performance
I also think Tony and Jones script
trying to make it have a contemporary
feel really helps you understand how
these things have a way
of of repeating themselves and so I I do
think it's important that we we teach a
new generation about these stories that
you know uh for some reason
anti-Semitism is on the rise again and
it's like we have to check it we have to
look at it and we have to go no no hate
no lies and we can't do it you know and
you have to remind people what happened
and and what the truth is and I think to
do that in a compelling way certainly
for future Generations you have to come
at it with a fresh story and a fresh
idea it's your birthday
and your your wife called this morning
and asked if I'd surprise you with a
cake
um but we got really busy and we worked
through lunch I didn't have time to go
out but there's a really nice Bakery
just down there so either you come with
me and I'll buy you a cake or please
just explain to your wife that I tried
because frankly I find her quite scary
she's very intimidating with someone
like Otto I get you know the pressure's
on because it's a it's a sort of a very
very well-known character and has been
interpreted many times before but again
you just got to lean into what the
script you've been giving is trying to
do what's the Arc of that script and how
do you help express it through your
character you know the the people that
um the Anne Frank house in Amsterdam and
and Frank House in La were all really
really generous with me in terms of
giving me footage and resources and
material I was trying to find as you do
in this situation I was trying to find
things I hadn't seen before to to for a
real you know to have a fresh take on it
and I so I was kind of interested in
what were the things that Otto didn't
want published in diary and getting to
see some of those and knowing how much
he was struggling uh within his own
family Dynamic for that period of time
when they were
locked up at apteca that was a really
interesting thing to know how much he
was struggling in his marriage and
couldn't do anything about it he
couldn't be alone and work it out he had
to sort of tough it out for that period
surrounded by people all the time and
just those little nuances and details of
someone's Humanity kind of make it feel
hopefully a little bit more relatable